with Porsha's new makan we can finally
say it the SUV takeover of luxury cars
is complete it's no longer good enough
to have just one SUV in your lineup oh
no you must have a wardrobe of SUVs the
makan is the little brother to the
Cayenne the Cayenne of course was
Porsches first SUV causing conniptions
among purist and then going on to
becoming the best-selling Porsche of all
time but why stop with two SUVs
mercedes-benz has not one not two but
five different SUVs each one cutting the
market into ever thinner slices of
course car makers can do this nowadays
because it's easier than ever to spin
off different models from a common set
of parts and measurements mercedes's new
GLA SUV for example is related to its
CLA sedan the makan is related to its
corporate cousin the audi q5 for Porsche
all of this makes a lot of sense because
in the past the company was leaving
money on the table customers who loved
the car makers small two-door sports
cars still needed something larger for
their families and we're going off and
buying BMWs and range rovers and the
like they would buy a porsche SUV if
only porsche made one now what was
interesting was at this time volkswagen
was also interested in developing a
full-size SUV VW and porsche formed a
partnership and out of that came the
volkswagen touareg the audi q7 and the
Porsche Cayenne after dipping their
collective toe in the water about a
decade ago luxury car companies are
going all-in for SUVs and for good
reason their customers really really
liked them the ability to carry a lot of
stuff the reassurance of all-wheel drive
and a higher seating position has become
a must-have combination and there's no
sign of this abating as I speak
companies like bentley rolls-royce and
lamborghini are all engineering big tall
suvs of their own forget about low slung
sports cars and sleek limousines in the
luxury market the only way to go is up